توتر جديد عنوانهم مقاتلات اف 35 او اكثر
تي 5 قد يندلع لبن بدا وقد يتصاعد بين كل
من انقره واشنطن وفقا تحذيرات تركيا
الرئيس التركي اردوغان وجه رساله الى
الولايات
المتحدها اذا لم تلتزموا بوعودكم حول
وببايع انقره مقاتلات اف 16 واف 35 فعليكم
دفع الثمن مشددا اي اردوغان على ان بلاده
دفعت للولايات المتحده واحد فصل اربعه
مليار دولار ثمن طائرات مقاتله ولم
تستلمها حتى الان بسبب المماطله الامريكيه
لكن ماذا عن سبب الغاء او تاجيل تلك
الصفقه حتى اشعار اخر بالرغم من انها وقعت
قبل سنوات الخلاف مشاهدينا بين الولايات
المتحده وتركيا والذي ادى الى ازاله انقره
من برنامج اف 35 بدا بعد ما قررت انقره
شراء انظمه الدفاع الصاروخيه روسيه روسيه
ومع من طراز اس 400 ردا طبعا على ذلك
الغطاء واشنطن بيع طائرات لتركيا وهي من
طراز اف 35 في يوليو من العام 2019 معلله
ذلك بانها قد تسرب اسرارا عسكريا الى
روسيا وتكمل تلك الاسرار بان المنظومه
الروسيه قد تكشف نقاط الضعف طائرات الاف
35 وتنقل البيانات الى موسكو وبالتالي
قدره الاخيره على مواجهه المقاتلات
الامريكيه وفي محاوله لتعديل الموقف ولو
قليلا اعلنت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان الرئيس
جوبادل يعتقد انه يجب على الولايات
المتحده بيع تركيا مقاتلات اف 16 بدل من
1,000 35 لتحديث اسطولها الحالي لكن رغم
ذلك لم يحدث اي تحدد رسمي بشان هذا الامر
قبل ذلك تواجه الاداره الديمقراطيه
الحاليه في الولايات المتحده من نواب
ديمقراطيين وجمه مين يرفضون طبعا بيع
الطائرات لتركيا وعلى راسهم السيناتور
الديمقراطيه رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه
في مجلس الشيوخ الذي اعلن مرارا بانه لن
يمارس صفقه الطائرات المقاتله لتركيا سواء
اف 35 او حتى مقاتلات اف 16
[موسيقى]